[موسيقى]
دخلت الخدمه في سلاح الجو الملكيه
البريطاني في عام
1938 اي قبل سنه واحده من اندلاع الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
[موسيقى]
هذا الحجم الصغير صعب استهدافها بل ومنحها
سرعه وقدره كبيره على المناوره خلال
الاشتباكات الجويه
فاير
12.7 مليمتر وتمت زيادتها لاحقا
لثمانيه مدافع كل هذه المدافع اعطتها قوه
نيران كبيره
[موسيقى]
اثبت فير كانت هي طائره الاعتراض الاساسيه
للتعامل مع المقاتلات الالمانيه الرئيسيه
في هذا الوقت من
109 كما بالفعل اسقطت العديد منها في
الاشتباكات فوق بريطانيا ودول القاره
الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
تم تصنيع اكثر من 20 الف طائره من فاير
خلال فتره خدمتها والتي امتدت حتى عام
1961 كما خدمات ايضا في عدد من القوات
الجويه حول العالم منها القوات الجويه
الامريكيه والقوات الجويه الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]